james is joining us in denver colorado
james how can we help
hey how are you guys doing today well
we're having a blast how can we help
um so i'll try to keep it short but i've
got a
couple of attributes to this question so
about a year ago i uh gave a personal
loan to my girlfriend of about three
thousand dollars
um of that she has paid back fifteen
hundred so she saw us
fifteen hundred left on the agreement
since that time three things have
happened number one
because of the pandemic she had to take
a different job
making about half the amount of money
she was making
number two we both started financial
peace
and we are both on baby step two and
number three
we recently got engaged
we're getting married in about six
months
given all that's going on right now i
kind of feel like
it would be best to just
forgive the rest of the loan it doesn't
feel right to me to keep it
but i'm also afraid because our
relationship has always been a
a 50 50 partnership that it's going to
come off
like i'm trying to lord over her
or be better than her
and i also have all this debt still pay
off so
i was wondering uh should i just go
ahead and try to
tell her not to pay it back and how do i
approach that without seeming
weird okay
you sound weird you do sound weird
because i would never utter the phrase
my fiance owes me money in a billion
years
that sentence can't come out of of my
mouth no
i don't know how it comes out of your
mouth i don't think this is a her issue
this is a usu this is a wii issue john
my goodness i don't even know where to
start well yeah there's a lot here
so if you are not able to have a
conversation that says
hey i did something stupid we didn't
know
we didn't know about um the we didn't
have the wisdom
about loaning money to people that were
in
uh romantic relationships with or
friendships or family right
give it away or say no
dude we're not we're done with this debt
repayment situation
if that becomes a lording over a power
struggle
man you guys got to get to a premarital
counselor
tomorrow right you are not in a position
to get married because dude the
conversations y'all will be having about
kids and work and where we're going to
live and family and i'm sick i need some
support
they get harder and harder and harder
this is a
simple one absolutely
when is the wedding day uh
about six months six months from now
six months from now you walk down the
aisle she doesn't owe you any more
money i guess i mean i guess i guess if
she breaks up with you today or you
break it with her then we can talk about
that but if you're getting married it
becomes our money it's hourly i mean i
married stacy she had a master's in
broadcast journalism i
married her student loans
yeah yeah so so it wasn't like it wasn't
like oh i'm paying
every time i wrote a check and they go
well i'm paying your master's degree
that's right no you're in it together so
james you you said you're you're both 50
50. is that a hard
who is this more challenging for
i i feel like it would be more
challenging for her
um it because that has always been a
great
sense of pride for her right that she is
you know her own person she's making a
way in the world
you know i i feel like it's something
that comes from
the way she was raised her family
dynamics certainly something that i
personally would would push back against
and i
agree with everything that you're saying
oh well then i think you just have to
have a straight up conversation here to
say hey
you are who you are you're you're an
independent woman you're all these
wonderful things
i loaned you some money big deal it's
gonna be our money
don't even think of it that way you're
gonna help pay this whole thing off
anyway yeah
and this whole 50 50 talk brother it's
.50.50
and you're about to become one you're
gonna have to get with somebody and work
on that before you all
attach yourselves to each other forever
man and don't
be very careful about psychoanalyzing
your fiance
you'll need to get with the premarital
counselor today